there's the false belief that my
qualification to be in a leadership
position is directly tied to my
intelligence my performance my ability
to make right decisions my ability to
project confidence whatever whatever one
of those or some combination of those
but that's not your job your job is to
lead other people who are smarter more
talented more aware have different
points of view and ultimately the only
thing you're going to have to do is make
a decision like we give you a position
of authority because you're accountable
for the team but you will have to make
decisions and when things go right
you're going to have to give away the
credit and when things go wrong you're
going to have to take the responsibility
that's why we give you more money that's
why we give you more perks because
you're ultimately accountable yeah and
it's actually so much more inspiring
when you lead that way because you're
able to learn I constantly want to be
surrounding myself with people of all
levels who are teaching me in the
business and I don't think that title
has anything to do with someone's
intelligence and what they're going to
contribute to the business and if you
approach it from that perspective you
can learn so much from everybody in your
business